das ist eine slipeinlagen mein name ist
luca und meine freundin jule war bei
hallo erstmal jude war an einem
drogeriemarkt unterwegs und hat
verschiedene produkte gekauft die
eigentlich ausschließlich für frauen
sind und von denen sie denkt dass ich
nicht genau weiß wofür sie gedacht sind
die wird sie mir jetzt nach und nach
hier ins bild geben und ich sag dann was
ich denke wo für die produkte gemacht
sind als erstes habe ich etwas was
glaube ich eher raguhn ii genau
und davon gibt es jetzt eine neuere
version dass das sie dass das hirn drin
aber kann sie mir sagen wie so eine art
und haargummi heißt oder wie generell
dieses spiral hat schickt also sondern
wales haargummi würde ich sagen heißt
haargummi normales und ich hier soll ich
jetzt sagen sie das hier heißt invisible
so heißen die haare ist generell aber
dass es jetzt 1 kranz schlief und der
firma inklusive ins bein schießt und
eben diese haken die dieser diesen stoff
außen von hagen aber das eigentlich das
schilliger als normales hagemann macht
das gerät einfach so rein und dann hat
man liest habe ich das hier für dich
das legt man sich unter die augen ich
dachte dass er zu augen platz gegen
augenringe oder so wie es auch viel zu
groß eine zu große augen das hieße ja
dankbar dass in die schuhe
und das sind dann so wärmer oder was das
ist
[Musik]
für die hacken darauf meine schuhe anhat
ist das ganze gewicht zwar sie vorne auf
dem vordersten sei das ist ein stück
plastik wieder deutlich gemütlicher
werden sind geht das ist und jedem etwas
kann abziehen aber du kannst es dir auch
unter die augen kommt dass ihr da habe
ich das mal abgeklebt was das auch
hangover 3 und 1 zu sonnen shop machen
also hier steht braucht wie wir es jetzt
locker
[Musik]
das kann man locker shop kaufen hangover
3 in 1 af 447 when you don't also das
ist die creme fürs gesicht ist dass
dieses spray was man essen kann ein
bisschen d oh nein ich dachte die
refresh und dann wieder verhüten make up
zu fixieren das ist quasi geschütztes
umwelteinflüsse spucke das riecht nach
kokos ja du wirst aufkommen das ist aber
ich glaub du wirst nicht wissen warum
man es macht das ist quasi eine
kombination das ist ja hier steht ja
schon drauf fingers und ich glaube das
ist nagellackentferner aber extra
starker markt lag entferner falls nicht
es sieht nicht so aus als bester zum
kassamarkt lage sieht halt so aus als
wäre das so alkohol nagellackentferner
die man völlig auf seine normalen
fingernägel macht aber halt auch so fade
fingernägel arbeit hast brauchst du denn
damit sie überhaupt auf den
geld nein mit dem neuen studio wenn du
jetzt dir diesen lagen dann kurz wie
christa den er jetzt auf den finger
das ist kleber ja immer kleber geht kein
thema bin ließ das habe ich einen stift
da habe ich auch wieder abgeklebt wofür
genau ist dadurch auch sein macht marie
decke laufen guckst du das mal an du
machst du dich deine hand um diese weise
ist augenbrauen da sie ja das sieht man
doch immer da ist dieses kleine ding
setzt sich aus dieser mit kleinem in
ihren also ich finde hier kann man schon
erkennen dass das für augenbrauen ist du
kannst uns nicht mehr augenbrauen und
wimpern ausland aber jetzt habe ich hier
eine krone ich dass man auch meine hand
mache dass das schmiert man sich so in
die augen brauchen bekennt sich damit
die augenbrauen und dadurch werden die
so ein bisschen voluminöser das ist hat
er seine geteilt die spitze und wenn man
damit dann mag man sich so kleine
härchen die augen so dichter das sieht
so aus wie wieder was dass man sich
nicht in die schule legt 2000 jahre
später also es sieht auf den ersten
blick sieht auf den ersten blick aus wie
so pflaster
die sind ja brutal viele die hier drin
sind aber die sind zu dünn pflaster
deswegen kann sein dass das trio die auf
die nase macht dann hast du mit dessen
abziehen
ein kaugummi sieht ein bisschen so aus
wachs streifen mädchen haben ja auch
manchmal so ein bisschen haaren im
gesicht lässt der wir uns jetzt im
snowboard werksseitig den dann gar nicht
mehr haben wenn ich kann ich damit
machen wir unterbinden kann wie auch
gleichzeitig dass die augenbrauen damit
fort da brauchte ich wurde wieder
abgeklärt wie es ist das ist das hier
trennte das ist von beiden seiten zu
benutzen auf der einen seite ist oder
ist das nachfüllen zum austauschen
es ist ein nach einer korrektur stimmt
wenn sie gar das ist ja schlimmer als
raketentechnik kennedy seinen sind
yannick reagiert und über mal zusammen
mit ganz einfach das dann korrigieren
deshalb weil sind im keller tintenkiller
hat nicht mehr so gerettet in der schule
warten wäre so die leute die sonst
hinten kieler hatten mit so zum stift
oder hattet ihr dieses klee bedingt ich
hatte so als es aus und wiederfand und
dann kann man damit zu kleben dann kam
aus dem rüssel dieses reist als ließ das
produkt habe ich das hier für dich
das heißt engel dieser hier stehe ich
auch drauf und damit kann man sich die
die haare kämmen und warum sind einige
weil bei diesen kleinen sind und weil
die relativ schmerzfrei die haare können
exakt das auch der grund warum ich die
so gern mag und auch jahre der teddy das
ist natürlich wahnsinn kann das alter
das ist es ist wie wir dann so kopf
griff bekommen also wenn doch damit
können jetzt habe ich etwas heißen sie
und das sogar vielleicht gar nicht so
viel miete kennen aber es ist eher was
für mädchen benutzen würde das den stein
nein es ist seife nein wenn man es
benutzt wird zwar ist das vielleicht so
ein rauerer peelings spannend ja ok aber
ich dachte wenn der wasser drüber läuft
und das beispiel dann kann man damit
bestimmt irgendwie von jack schwammes
kontakt mit alkohol
oder man benutzt als anwalt genau jetzt
mal wieder was einfach ist was du
wirklich direkt wissen ja da ist ja das
ziel den benutzt du wenn man gerade
beispielsweise das gesicht gewaschen hat
und dann hat man zeit sauber gemacht und
dann hat man so eine feuchtigkeitscreme
drauf oder so und dann das als grundlage
für das make up
es ist einfach ein ticket abzuwechseln
tim augen regatten das meine ich doch
das ist die grundlage von make-up nein
macht eigentlich benutzt man erst von
dayton und dann benutzt man sieht gerade
gekappt danke das habe ich etwas sehr
nächsten typisches für dich kredit
gerichte die wir mit bittere ich glaube
dass jetzt tatsächlich eine binde
das ist so etwas ähnliches wie eine
binde das ist eine slipanlage eine
slipeinlagen es klebt man sich vorsehen
seine unterwäsche eventuell austretende
flüssigkeiten zu empfangen
jetzt hat ein ganz komisches volk das
letzte wort ist das hier sind dass diese
trotz sind das nicht diese dinger diese
diese zeit positiv war nur in amerika
sondern übrigens da trennt sich die alle
gegessen haben
obwohl das eigentlich so für
spülmaschinen tabs waren oder
waschmaschine oder so heißt es hier
fühlt sich das kann man gar nicht
beschreiben sich das anfühlt darf ich
nur kurz frage ob man das noch offen
macht bevor man das nutzen so das ist
doch kein schwamm dann werde ich voll
mit wasser eben nicht aber hey wird es
wird so den fall eingeführt sind ja alle
mädchen dies wäre bei mir auch immer die
schwaben das make-up so ins gesicht
aber wer jedem sprach ist heißt das der
das ganze papier auch sorgt man darf
hier brauchen dass die familie sich das
überlegt und dadurch dass der held aus
dem ton ist braucht man nur ganz ganz
unfälle eben nichts aufgebaut
an der stelle wird das heutige bietet
auch beenden wenn die lieben freunde ein
riesiges dankeschön an jule dafür dass
du die sachen hier ausgesucht haben euch
meine reaktion auf einige typische
frauen produkte gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich sehr sehr wohl bei einem daumen
hoch von euch unter dem video ihr freund
schreibt mir gern bauen in die
kommentare ob ich sage und eventuell mal
einen zweiten teil machen soll oder ob
ich mal typische männer produkte kaufen
und jude sein soll für diese abonniert
meinen kanal danke
[Musik]